joined by Labor's Shadow Justice
secretary Steve Reed hi good morning
thanks for joining us which of those two
candidates is labor would you most like
to face well frankly it doesn't make
very much uh difference because after
all of the Ruckus that we've seen in the
House of Commons the tour is fighting
each other like rats in a sack over the
last few weeks We've Ended up with the
two continuity candidates both of them
very senior lieutenants in Boris
Johnson's government both of them voted
and supported every one of the 15 tax
hikes that were delivered under Boris
Johnson both of them equally responsible
for the high tax low growth economy that
the conservatives have delivered so it's
a bit like an episode of Doctor Who
where he's going to regenerate into a
new character we just don't know yet
whether Boris Johnson is going to come
back reincarnated as Rishi or Liz but
they're both responsible for every
single economic era that has been made
under the Johnson government and both in
power and you're not absolutely that's
right well that the country is crying
out for a fresh start right now we know
that the cost of living crisis is really
hurting people hard
if we really want the Fresh Start then
we need a general election and the
choice should go over to the people of
this country not just a few thousand
members until after day week after week
saying that it's not going to happen
well we don't know do we we don't know
we do we don't know that they're not
that they know that they're absolutely
going to be struggling over the next six
months with the cost of living crisis a
situation in Ukraine et cetera Etc the
last thing they want is a general
election because they'll lose well
possibly we'll see there has to be one
within two years but they're both going
around saying now that we need a fresh
start well Goodness Me they've been in
power for 12 years these two have been
two of the most senior figures in the
government that has created the
devastation that they're now trying to
claim uh they're they're against they
they voted for all of those for those
tax hikes they were both they were
coming on your show and other shows
covering up for Boris Johnson's lies and
law breaking and the mockery he made of
the sacrifices of the British people uh
during the lockdown they can't just
launder their reputations they were all
complicit uh every single step of the
way so the idea here that they can
represent any kind of of a fresh start
it's for the birds the reason I was
asking about which one you would prefer
to see across the dispatch boxes because
in the polls that we are looking at um
list trust does not do as well as uh
Rishi sunak when it comes to
um being able to stand up to labor well
you know labor is prepared to take on
whoever the conservatives put up as
leader of course we would because that's
what happens in a general election but
if I have either of these two characters
think that they can whitewash their
records and pretend that they had
nothing to do with the economic
mismanagement that's created this
conservative cost of living crisis then
it won't wash because they have defended
it and voted for it every single step of
the way and whichever of them is elected
whenever the general election comes we
will take them on on the record that
they are that they are part of my belief
is the country desperately needs a fresh
start now the cost of living crisis are
hurting immensely the reason that we've
got a high tax economy right now is
because we have a low growth economy
because the conservatives choked off
growth 12 years ago when they first come
in and that has been a pattern that
we've seen all the way through if they
had grown the economy at the same rate
that the last Labor government did then
right now there would be 35 billion
pounds more money in the exchequer to
spend on public services without going
to the public for a single penny more in
tax the ultimate cause of their failure
is they have not grown the economy why
didn't you applaud Boris Johnson's last
pmqs yesterday
well it was absolute hypocrisy that we
were that we were treated to there he
did not apologize for a single one of
the mistakes that he's made we've had
prime ministers in this country came off
I mean he's gone this is in this country
for 300 300 years here's the first prime
minister to have to be dragged out of
office because he was unfit for the
office that he holds and we haven't
heard a single word of apology for all
of the mistakes that that got him here
and all of those conservative MPS who in
the end because they thought it was in
their own personal self-interests to
knife him in the back having done that
then stood up and applauded it and I
thought it was rank hypocrisy well a lot
of conservative MPS would not have
particularly cared for Tony Blair for
all sorts of reasons that we don't need
to go into here but they're still
applauded when healer you can't applaud
somebody who has bought the whole of
politics into disrepute you know the
lies that we had all the way through the
lockdown covering up party Gates the
attempt to change the rules over Owen
Patterson's law breaking lobbying in
order to cover up for what he had done
the promotion of a man that he knew at
the time was a sex pest to Deputy uh
deputy chief whip we know why would you
applaud a man that had done all of this
but you know you've seen him off he's
done for all of those reasons and you
kept his feet to the flames and he's
gone would it not have just been good
grace to stand up and Applause I I think
Boris Johnson has disrespected the
people of this country and the office
that he holds and he does not deserve
credit for having bought the whole of
politics into disrepute it's a quite
different thing to disagree with
somebody but respect what they've done
I'm afraid Boris Johnson through that
respect uh away when he himself
disrespected the British people by
partying his way through uh lockdown
I'm just explaining okay Theresa May
what do you think about her not standing
up well that's
to Theresa May for a very long time I
can account for myself but not for her
but Boris Johnson brought politics into
disrepute by his behavior he does not
deserve to be applauded he needed to
leave office much sooner than he did the
conservative MPS including Liz and Rishi
propped him up until they thought it was
in their own self-interest not the
country's interest to get rid of him
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us on the pleasure thank you